c'est un poste que j'occupe depuis mes 6
ans gardien de but un rôle passion un
rôle méconnu et souvent décrié on a
tendance souvent à incriminer le gardien
de but quand l'équipe subit est
justement un but alors je vais vous
montrer que c'est pas si facile que ça
d'occuper ce poste et je vais vous le
montrez ce soir avec les gardiens de
l'étoile sportive de trappes
l'équipe fanion évolue en régionale 2
c'est le deuxième plus haut niveau
régional allez suivez moi c'est parti
et donc je suis avec loïc qui est
entraîneur de gardiens à l'étoile
sportive de trappes
bonsoir loïc le poste de gardien de but
juste si on fait une petite introduction
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est un
sport individuel à l'intérieur d'un
sport collectif est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cette présentation tout
avant tout à fait d'accord avec vous
c'est un sport individuel pour un
gardien puisque il est tout seul sur le
terrain il est presque considéré comme
un individu à part dans l'équipe même
s'il peut avoir un rôle de vice
capitaine puisqu'il a le droit à la
parole sous terrain c'est un rôle qui a
évolué en gaule pas aujourd'hui comme
mongolia 20 à 25 ans quels sont les
trois qualités s'il ya trois qualités
adressé par un gardien de but quelles
sont elles
la première c'est la qualité mentale
faut très solide dans sa tête la
deuxième je dirais que
il faut avoir une capacité à entraîner
les autres
et à commander comme un capitaine
puisque savoir travailler sur une
défense la troisième je dirais que c'est
la négation
là je vais pouvoir m'entraîner avec le
gardien de l'équipe une senior
quels sont les exercices qu'on va faire
ce soir pour regarder un but de
l'exercice est toujours là répétition
prises de balle coordination travail au
sol
c'est toujours un peu près le même
travail parce que c'est toujours les
mêmes choses qui se reproduit sur le
terrain et
il faut les revoir en permanence allez
je vais aller rejoindre tout de suite
l'entraînement des gardiens
[Musique]
j'avais beaucoup parce que c'est
physique
[Musique]
et
je suis avec le gardien de l'équipe
senior à l'équipe une seigneur qui
évolue en régionale 2 déjà qu'est ce qui
t'a donné toi envie de faire ce poste le
poste de gardien de but moi tout
franchement en fait j'aurais bien voulu
jouer en attaque
en fait j'étais très très doué côté
gardien de but
à l'époque dans les quartiers un bain en
afrique notamment
j'ai joué au goal dès l'âge de 8 9 ans
petit dernière question sur
l'entraînement convient de faire est ce
que c'est important pour toi de les
faire pour te préparer au mieux pour les
dimanches et est-ce que tu trouve ça
difficile du coup spécifique ça reste
toujours difficile en même temps c'est
c'est le bon moyen aussi pour être
toujours informe donc qui vient on
transforme la sphère ces mois passés par
ça donc la raison pour laquelle je
travaille pour être au top dimanche
merci on va te laisser travailler et il
espère que voilà je vous ai donné envie
en tout cas de découvrir ce poste que
voilà qui me passionne que j'occupe
depuis mai et mes 6 ans aller au travail
sur les terrains